Those are the viewers who don't know.
Headstart was a nationwide attempt to,
to add additional education to
the lives of disadvantaged kids,
especially,
you know,
at the,
at the preschool level.
And basically what happened,
what was that they actually did show
improvements in academic achievement
initially.
So in grade one and grade two they
were performing above their peers.
But then the difference in improvement,
the difference in performance started
to decrease and then by both the grade
grade five,
grade six that differences
and disappeared completely.
So there was no evidence
whatsoever of that,
of that either have a stable one time,
longterm gain in cognitive ability or
what people were really hoping was that if
you intervene early enough,
you get something that would sort of,
Paul would turn into a positive feedback
loop and the gains would actually
advance across time.
And what ended up happening with the
headstart research basically was the
conclusion that it produced no
cognitive improvements whatsoever.
Although more kids who
went through headstart,
um,
graduated from high school,
fewer of them were delinquent,
more of them,
fewer of them became pregnant
teenage in the teenage years.
And more of them went to colleges.
But that seemed to be because
they were better socialized,
not because they were in any way.
It had been made smarter.
So that was a really tremendous
disappointment because it was a bipartisan
attempt to come to grips with the
fundamental issues that sort of be deviled
structural poverty in the United States.
No one was happy about that outcome.
I can tell you.